how are you how are you sir yeah it's
good to see you man thanks for having
yeah so how's the game right now the
game is you know rusty but good now why
a comeback at age 37 I haven't played in
four years so when I when I hurt myself
here with the Knicks it was pretty much
my career was over and you know after a
couple years my body and everything
start feeling good and I was like maybe
I should you know try training and you
know just play record recreationally and
after about a year doing that I was like
hold on they're like I have no eggs and
pains you know why not give it a real
shot you know even though I'm 37 you
know I feel a lot younger because I took
a lot of time off when you give this
though you know I'm pushing this summer
going into the farm I want to play so
I'm 40
so you know I have a good have a good
good chance I know going into to play in
the NBA
yeah for sure with who they don't matter
have you talked to anybody I talked to a
bunch of teams last year but you know it
went with free agency we'll see how
things shake out but the goal is have a
good summer and you know playing some
summer league yeah it was in my she
white chocolate there Jason Williams
playing those pickup games yes like he's
dominating yeah he's good right could
Jason Williams play in the NBA right now
I think if he wanted to if he trained
hard you know if he was healthy he could
basketball it's all about being healthy
and being able to get up and down the
court and you know do the things you can
do because your skills never your skills
never leave you it's just if you can
keep up and keep the pace and that's why
I wouldn't play in the d-league just to
see if I can keep up with those young
guys can you dunk yeah okay yeah not
that that means you can play right yeah
it's amazing you think you've made it
when you can dunk like all of a sudden
you can play yeah and then when you get
there it's like the last thing you want
to do is
because you worried about coming down
you know Landon what's your what's your
memory though if I said describe your
NBA career and at its peak what would
that moment be if you were telling
somebody who didn't see you play um I
would probably say the Dallas Mavericks
serious because it just you know it has
so many different storylines and it was
just a great series to be a part of it
was probably one of the most exciting
playoff series to be a part of but what
did you do what did I do
yeah I mean I played me game telling
them what did Baron Davis do ah man you
got busy yeah I just got you with the
Warriors I was with the warrior and you
got busy yeah we were we were the
underdog the eighth seed and we beat the
Dallas Mavericks 25 a game yeah in that
serious yeah
on another see I don't really I'll just
tell people you know I got busy it's
exciting go YouTube you know watch the
games it was rockin in there the busiest
you ever got in a game the busiest yeah
hmm how many points do you like
throughout your life most points you
scored again uh I mean when I was when I
was little I scored like 55 points when
I was in middle school
okay did you score 55 on Adam Levine
yeah it was a rival you know they were a
rival school and you know me coming from
South Central going to a school like
crossroads you know that and really had
you know somebody who like took
basketball serious but like as their
rich kid school
not so much a rich rich kids I mean some
rich kids but not more like our arts and
some performance arts and science and
and so I you know I was wasn't there for
science or our
there because hey I wanted a good
education and I want to play basketball
and not have to worry about you know all
the other good Adam Levine play yeah he
was good you know it was like the
remember the episode of Fresh Prince of
bel-air when he kept he kept scoring
scoring a score that's kind of like how
it was and were you The Fresh Prince
before The Fresh Prince
I was The Fresh Prince yeah yeah it was
like The Fresh Prince means allen
iverson
middle school yeah yeah that's a scary
thought there a little bit so there was
no Uncle Phil it was like hey you go
back to the hood everyday or Adam Levine
got lit up I mean the guy really hasn't
recovered his life has gone to hell
we just had Carmelo in studio and he
wouldn't commit to who's the best player
in the game right now mm-hmm
would you you know it's tough to say so
it's not a foregone conclusion Steph
Curry's the best player in the game
well right now Steph Carey is playing
the best basketball and he is the best
player and he's the reigning MVP so if
we're drafting and I give you first pick
I will probably take LeBron James why'd
your voice get lower there sure our
people afraid to not pick LeBron I mean
you have to be I have to be I would take
Steph Curry and then let me you take I
take Anthony Davis he's gonna be like
the third Pig okay okay you get LeBron
okay you a draft okay go ahead you take
staff
I'll take staff I'll take lebra I got
Anthony Davis see how that works
yeah and I got those now who do you go
um I'll take DeMarcus Cousins
okay that's not game over game over game
over yeah who's next
hmm maybe we just do two on to harden
you can have direct that would be bad
I'll take Durant
I'll take risk I gotta take somebody
else and make you take hard hmm
so I'm building a team here yeah so I
got Durant Steph Anthony Davis I'm gonna
go quite Leonard and hurt Yaman hurt
that was just shot right there
harden now that was a kidney saying I'm
actually gonna take Carmelo Anthony yeah
I'm gonna round out my five mm-hmm with
clay Thompson
ooh let's play ball okay and for my
point guard I'm going to probably take
well I am gonna take Kyrie Irving cuz
actually LeBrons gonna be the point
you got chemistry issues matter he's
gonna be the - no way you got some
issues
no with boogie Kyrie there's drama
there's no drama yeah I don't you can't
have Kyrie and LeBron you have them now
they don't complement each other yeah
they do
LeBron when LeBron is your primary ball
handler and your primary playmaker it
works because it frees Kyrie up to do
what he did in the first round of the
playoffs what do you know okay what
about this Clippers trade Blake Griffin
Oklahoma City uh-huh for Kevin Durant
that's possible would you do that Houma
City for sure cuz that works if you
think you're losing Durant now that
works
or who gets the better end of that deal
that's tough
the Clippers probably you know you get
around ya cuz you get that that's but
that's basically when big Blake Griffin
was out you know if they had someone
like Durant in that spot you know that
three spot that's pretty much all they
need now Baron is making a comeback here
but he also has a documentary coming out
the drew that's coming coming out Friday
at 8:00 Eastern on Showtime
yes all right now explain what the drew
is the drew is is the league that was
formed over forty two years ago and
south-central Watts and the league
started as an opportunity to keep kids
off the streets from joining gangs and
getting involved in drugs and so BK it
was a it was a local league that was you
know just after-school activity it grew
into a summer program League and now
forty over forty years later it's the
premium summer pro-am league in the
summer and it has you know James Harden
demar derozan klay Thompson Seth Curry
JaVale McGee played in there Kenneth
Faried you know LeBron came out Kobe
came out so it's now kind of like the
premier summer league in the summer and
it still takes place in watch confident
now they moved it to a bigger location
but you know basically it's it's a
summer league where the community in
south central that's all they really
have an opportunity for kids to see
their favorite NBA players it's a place
for redemption where guys who didn't
make it who still need basketball in
their lives
it's intimate it's an amazing thing
that's happening you know and a gang in
drug-infested neighborhood that has
limited resources you look at all of
those players who were there and what
the game means and just like it gives it
gives hope like these kids can say all
right these guys actually made something
of their lives
is that part of the documentary of you
know whoever these kids are now looking
at or these kids or these guys who are
coming back to play that they had dreams
and saw it through these other players
we went into Julie yeah I just think
that uh it's a recurrent cycle you know
ten years ago you know 15 mile 15 years
ago yet Darrell right and Trevor reason
guys like that you know watching you
know other NBA players play and you know
now you have young kids that you know go
and watch Trevor Ariza and Darrell right
play and I think that for the kids in
these neighborhoods they can't afford to
go to Staples Center they can't afford
to go to UCLA and you see us USC
basketball game so you know that right
that right there is all in everything
that they have besides their dreams and
then to see an NBA player to see
somebody in college that you can
actually walk up to talk to touch it
just kind of it crystallizes your dream
a little bit more that's cool Friday and
it'll be at 8:00 Eastern on Showtime
it's called the drew documentary
produced and directed by Baron Davis
what do you think is straight out of
Compton I loved it I thought it was good
were you friends with guys from NWA yeah
well I'm cool with Dre I'm cool with joy
always been a big fan of cube and you
know he's always been okay could cube
really mess around and get a
triple-double man he got it he messed
around and got a triple Dunham on it but
it's yeah foot is in the video but who
who counts their stats in a pickup game
here Baron I mean if you from LA we take
baskets others tabulate that for me I
don't need to do it right you also did
Crips and bloods Crips and bloods made
in America was stacy peralta direct it
yeah it was it was the first documentary
that I did and I wanted to do it because
you know I came from that neighborhood
and you know there was always like a
misconception and nobody really knew the
history and the origin were you
affiliated with Crips or Bloods
in a sense I mean you live there you're
automatically you had to pick sides or
they pick you a little both you know a
little of both for me I was always a
neutral but you know veered towards one
side or another because of the
neighborhood I lived in but being an
athlete did that allow you a little and
allow me yeah loud me a little bit more
freedom and you know basketball was
actually like the peace mechanism that
you know if I was from this side of town
I could go on that side and you know if
I'm playing basketball like yeah were
you from like I'm from over there like
but you good though Seaton said that he
was doing some research which is really
rare on this program he said that there
was an i-team report here yeah some kind
of connection that you had with somebody
or your wives and seat and said I'm
gonna try and get these guys to figure
it out okay right barren right here we
go
someone who's been on the show many
times but we've never man we've seen in
person once Will Ferrell no not not
famous in that sense okay are they an
athlete or a musician or an actor I
would say more a professional gambler
gambler professional gambler
tattoos possibly in witness protection I
was guessing Brent Musburger until he
got the tattoo oh yeah Rob Dibble no not
famous not famous no infamous yes yeah
oh that's my guy bicycle Shane Irving's
gonna a tattoo on his head yeah he's
gonna love him
is fun yeah the quote oh my god that I
got from [ __ ] okay you got to do it in
Shea's voice for Baron I mean let me
just dial it up here as there here we go
he said I was at his nephews birthday
party and drank all its beer I ate all
his food and passed out on his couch
watching football so his wife is friends
with your wife yes I never would have
guessed right not in a million years I
couldn't guess that and his daughter and
my son are the same age and so we've
been talking about arranging a marriage
oh my god it all happens
be careful changes from now it's great
to see you don't think things thank you
doing some amazing stuff and you also
did the Sonny Vaccaro that the soul man
3433 SPN you produce that which was
great but make sure you tune in it'll be
at 8 o'clock Eastern on Showtime the
drew the documentary film produced by
and directed by Baron Davis great to see
you thank you thank you thanks for
stopping by the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience